LINA: I feel like relationships
complicate
everything.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LINA: Emily's actually
the biggest
matchmaker you've ever seen.
EMILY: Speaking about
personalize lives, this
prompted Lina to start asking
everyone personal questions.
LINA: How did you and your
husband get together?
Do you ever matchmake people?
When you look at all of us,
do you matchmake us?
PHIL: No.
They find each other.
LINA: Really?
Oh.
A lot of people seem to enjoy
giving me advice.
One of the reasons my parents
wanted me to come to MIT was
so I could find a really
nice MIT man.
They want my husband
to make the money.
I want to be a strong woman
who can support herself.
I'm going to be raising my own
household of one person.
I'm going to live by myself on a
really nice mountain next to
a waterfall, play music, just
commune with God and nature.
They tell me I'm really weird.
ANTHONY: Dating here is just
like dating anywhere else.
IKE: I'm single.
I'm single.
I can't commit right now.
ROO-RA: I just don't
like relationships.
IKE: Girls like too much
attention, you know?
ROO-RA: I'm not into the
whole clingy thing.
IKE: Because they're going
to be, oh could you
come take me out?
Call me.
Text me.
ROO-RA: Let's hang out all the
time and call each other--
I don't know.
IKE: I can't do all that.
It's too much.
Too much pressure.
ROO-RA: Too much drama.
[MUSIC PLAYING]